we've had some certified badasses on the
show we had francis pagano the ufc
heavyweight champion the world but i
mean ddp certified badass in the house
and you know what but i'm also an actor
you know he's he's a real badass
you know i dude i can help hang my own
but at 66 i'm all about peace and love
baby
it's like the old bobby bear song you're
the winner as far as i'm concerned you
win you know
i'm not trying to fight it by the way by
the way
for the folks who are still in their 40s
or 50s and they were convinced wrestling
was real he just ruined it for you
i always tell people it's not fake it's
pre-determined yeah the
it's a show it's a show yeah i got to
tell you it's a great story i was i was
uh
being interviewed because we did one of
the favorite wrestling movies out there
is ready to rumble and you know we're
doing the whole big you know gambit the
promoting and everything and everybody's
being so nice because wrestling's just
white hot you know in the 90s and that's
when it came out and
there's this one guy who's interviewing
me and i can tell
he just doesn't want to be there and so
as we get to the end of the interview i
said you know can i ask you a question
man you go sure i said you don't
appreciate what we do do you
he said honestly i said i asked you a
question yeah honestly because not
really
i said
okay so you don't like the whole
showmanship of it or whatever yeah well
it's fake and blah blah blah go let me
ask you a question
i said
uh are you like you guys you're from new
york city yo you a guy who likes to go
to place oh absolutely i love i love
broadway i said what's your favorite
uh broadway play and he said hands down
phantom of the opera and i looked around
and i said bro
i don't want to spoil this for you
but he doesn't really get burnt with oil
you know
you know and the crew just burst out
laughing right and
uh yeah i just said i said you know
every night i'm going out there with a
different opponent because it's a dance
it's a very
physical brutal dance and people think
it only happens on monday and friday in
a pay-per-view no it happens 24
to 27
nights a month
you get in a car you drive a hundred two
hundred three hundred miles to the next
town or fly from l.a to kansas city and
drive 100 200 300 miles the wear and
tear on your body
is off the chain and people can say
whatever they want about professional
wrestling
one thing remains that everyone
understands
you can't fake gravity
you know gravity wolf
it'll lift you up i mean you said you
your surgery what would you on your back
what did you talk about you had
something going with your back i i knew
this is a thing now we talked about hulk
a second you know from what i understand
hulk said eight
back surgeries because once you start
one they're coming
i ruptured my elf i didn't start
wrestling until i was 35. my career took
off when i was 40. that was in nineteen
by the way unheard of started when you
were thirty-five thirty-five most
professional careers are ending at that
point you're just getting this thing
started baby and it was really hard
because i came from a manager in a color
color come a color commentator spot and
i was running nightclubs so
for me to make that yo break because
one day they came up to me on the wcw at
the time i'm managing scott hall who i
called the diamond stud at the time and
i'm managing to free birds and magnum ta
who is dusty rhodes's right hand walks
up to me and he said listen deep
we're still going to let you do the
color commentating but we can't let you
do the you know the managing anymore i
go why i mean dude
what did i do wrong i go i'll fix it he
goes
honestly
you can't i go what do you mean i can't
he goes because
look at you
the hair had long unbelievable gorgeous
hair yeah yeah i'm freaking lots of gold
rocks golden air but you know the
clothes the bling the wraps i had these
girls called the diamond dolls yeah and
they were stripper hot it was like
smoking i know the type d yes you know
what i'm talking about
and the bottom line is
he's like the bling the rap the girls
nobody like everybody wants to be you
you're taking two we need you in the
ring bro do you know what he was getting
at no he was saying you basically i'm
too over the top of professional
wrestling how is that possible as a
manager
but what he said when he walked away he
said what we should have tried to do is
put you in a pair of tights and boots
and see if you can do this now i had
seven months left of my contract
at that point i was like you know i
never got in this business because i
tried it when i was 23. and three
matches hurt my knees it didn't work out
for me i wasn't ready for it then anyway
starting at 35
was really hard because when i can't
tell you how many times my body hit that
mat when i first got down that cold
gym
that tree and got seven different rings
in it and it's freezing in there i can't
tell you how many times my body hit that
mat and i thought man this fake [ __ ]
hurts like out
you know
so you know it's just the when i finally
got to
you know actually get there and then
find out okay now you can't do it like
seven months left to my contract so i
said the hell if i'm going down the
power plant
i'm going to learn how to wrestle now
the guys i was managing the free birds
the two of the greatest ever hall of
famers jimmy jam garvin michael psas
they looked at each other
and literally fell down laughing at me
because by the time you try to figure it
out because it's not like anything
you've ever done
if you're in a fight you're in a fight
you're in a fight fight with a mixed
martial artist you're in trouble because
those cats know all different types from
jiu jitsu to wrestling to boxing
striking everything like they're gonna
get you in every different angle but at
least you got your own you got two fish
you got something to go with in
professional wrestling it's a dance
and just falling flat on your back
there's nothing
normal about that so you're going to
reprogram your mind to understand how to
focus if you don't take as much of it to
fall from your shoulders to your hips
you know you can really hurt yourself so
the bottom line is you think that
learning those moves in the beginning
it's going to be the hardest thing
you've ever done
and now you're out there in front of 500
5 000
i've been in front of 101 000 people
[Music]
and
once you realize now you're on from
those people
now how do you make them care and think
about this when they know
that you know
and you know that they know that you and
your partner both know who's gonna win
before you walk out there how do you
make them care
you build real life characters and and i
i've often said this in my speaking
and
when paige joseph faulkenberg because
that was my real name before i change it
and i knew that name was never going to
draw any money in a world of
professional wrestling
when paige joseph fuckerberg stopped
trying to be this over the top
wrestling persona diamond dallas page
and diamond dallas page started taking
on the characteristics of paige joseph
falkenberg work ethic belief in oneself
discipline
man my career took off like a rocket
because i was bringing my own self to
the character and that's what every
single actor does
you know and creates backstory so now
though became all mine i am the oldest
rookie ever
inside my hall of fame ring it says work
ethic
equals dreams explanation
i love that i love that what a freaking
story you just told by the way uh in in
in a match you're saying all of it is
you know you kind of know who's gonna
win before has there ever been a time
where in the middle of it it changed
where you guys as the wrestlers made a
decision now you know what you're going
to win this one
but not like that though eddie guerrero
was one of the greatest wrestlers ever
he could do anything and we were having
a match at halloween havoc and this was
really got me to a place where eddie was
the good guy when we started i was the
bad guy but my diamond cutter finishing
maneuver because it came out of nowhere
people want to be surprised they want to
think they no no no no oh
they want to be surprised and again ours
is like ballet
meets broadway meets live acting
and eddie
he would come off that top rope to you
on the floor when nobody did that now a
lot of guys do it i did it you know but
at that time he was one of the only guys
who's doing it and he would be to jump
off that top deal which was probably
about 12 feet
so he's another 20 feet in the air and
he came down and how he landed and this
happened to me too at times when you
tear like a in between your ribs white
muscle
it's you can't breathe it hurts to
breathe and eddie never sold it in other
words he never told me he hurt himself
he kept going he kept going and we're
getting near the end of the match and i
go to pick him up he goes diamond cutter
i go no eddie go diamond cutter diamond
he was
okay hitler diamond underpinned him it
was a huge win for me
october of 1996 uh 1996.
1997 i'd be the wrestler of the year
well you were supposed to lose that
match and he was not injured he's like
ddp me now yes just just hit me hit me
with the freaking how quickly did it
register oh [ __ ] i'm about to win this
match uh i was like yeah i hope i don't
get in trouble
and did you what happened
because eddie was like he came out like
he was really he would jump off the top
rope and he would take his arm his leg
as far out and then he'd bring his knees
into his chest and he'd spring out he
goes and called it a frog splash he
wasn't doing that and i thought he just
should have rolled me up and just like
you know made something's really simple
to get the win but he didn't do it he
went diamond cutter i went okay
it was a huge win
for me
wow so so
96 96 so let me ask you so you know how
uh uh the game of football right okay
the quarterback's up there coach is
calling to play sometimes the players
like now i'm going to do what i'm going
to do and the coach loses their mind
they're going to be doing that what are
you doing it says now i'm going to throw
this over here can't say nothing about
and then there's that beef between the
player
when that happens there who's calling
who is vince calling saying what was
that all about how does that process go
that was actually eric bischoff who was
in charge at that point because we were
kicking their ass well we were going
back and forth in 96 97 98 we kicked
wwe's ass they almost went out of
business
nwo was the hottest thing it was
must-see tv this is how crazy it was
the top you know back then there was as
many channels as that but there's a lot
of them so on cable television
we would be
or or wwf would be number one in all of
cable and then we would be our wwf would
be
number two
number three and sometimes number four
we had the top
four shows
on all of cable and it was two different
shows we did nitro and uh thunder they
did raw and smackdown
it was crazy in the ratings originally
vince was doing like a 2.9 to a 3.2
that would be unbelievable today but the
universe has changed
we got those numbers up i thought
they're going to split one free i'm
going to get one five and you know you
know the one eight or whatever
no no
more people watched
more people watched and it's kind of
like the boston red sox and the yankees
those two teams hate each other and not
not so much the teams but the but the
fans
and if the if all of a sudden there was
no more red sox all those baseball fans
who watching red sox would start
watching soccer or something they
wouldn't watch the yankees you know
because they hate them so i don't
understand that but i my buddies i grew
up in jersey
they you know like made a plane crash
why would you say that like they're that
fanatical about it so that's what it was
in wcw so by the way were you going to
be i will you at that time like but but
was it that the world also say that
you're ahead of them like the doorway
because i know you guys had hulk hogan
you had you know eric bischoff you had
kevin nash you had scott hall you had
randy savage you had sting you had you
had so many guys scott steiner i mean
[ __ ] some of these nems bagwell norton
there was some legit lineup of what you
guys had yeah what were you ahead were
you like the yankees at the time or were
you the red sox underdog we were we were
the redheaded stepchild for the longest
time and then kevin nash and scott hall
one day they were on their tv
and the next day scott hall just showed
up on ours there was only five people
who knew
he's gonna walk through the crowd
walk through grab a microphone in the
middle of a match people like what the
hell is happening and then he said he's
uh we're gonna we want you we're gonna
bring our best three you bring your best
friend he puts out this challenge
it we call it a shoot you know like this
is this is not a work or it's not not
storyline it was
but nobody knew but the smallest handful
you know really tough to do during the
internet but you can still do it but you
don't know if it's real or not kevin
nash showed up he grabbed eric bischoff
and this had never been done vince
mcmahon would go on to have matches and
get thrown through stuff and slam
through stuff but it never happened
before eric bischoff
kevin nash grabbed them at six foot ten
picked him up over his head and
threw him
through the stage now it's set up to
break but he drops like 10 feet
through a broken stage down to the
ground and that's how they go off the
show
so now people are they they bought it
is vince because these guys were just on
tv and they were razor ramon and diesel
when those guys came on
they never said their names it was you
know who we are
so now it didn't they didn't have to
call them something else and their names
were cool scott hall kevin nash hall and
nash they became the outsiders it
changed the business
it made it what thursdays used to be
when seinfeld was on and stuff must see
tv right and guys would be picking up
the phone oh my god no switch over
switch over to wwf i'll switch over to
wcw
and through this
because it was so hot both of those guys
were best friends of mine we started
together i created scott hall's look
when he came in as a diamond stud
and he didn't he had the blonde hair and
a big walrus mustache and he completely
changed his look
and
he wanted to help me
back
you know and kevin nash we were tag team
partners and
he wanted to quit a bunch of times
because they were screwing them around
so bad that i would be like don't let
them beat you big man you're gonna be
one of the biggest names of all time and
he is
but even in his hall of fame speech he
thanked me because i got my
my home on the beach you know because a
dolly kept me in this you know keeping
that positive don't you know this you
know this you don't quit
you keep if you believe in it if you're
passionate about it you keep moving
towards it and it will happen and it may
not happen exactly when you wanted to
happen but it'll happen if you enjoyed
this short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]